hey y'all incentive catch here in this
titus video we're going to be going over
um some data science packages from the
tidy verse
i just recorded the tidy r and d player
video
and now i'm working on these lesser
known packages
um specifically reader uh stringer
four cats and i'm also gonna use a
little bit of ggplot2
just to show the examples because four
cats
uh isn't a great package to have just as
tables
so i figured ggplot2 is a good way to
highlight what four cats actually do
um these four packages um the most
important package is obviously ggplot2
um with the actual um visualization
capabilities and it's
ops made for it um but you know reader
is a package you kind of
have to use um to read in your data
again there's not a lot of actual
functionality in reader
it's mostly just reading in data and
writing in data
um string here again is pretty uh
stringer is pretty useful uh especially
since you know generally you're going to
work
a little bit with string data and i
figured i'd go over you know the main
functions of it i'm not going to go over
regular expressions because
frankly i'm terrible at regular
expressions i think it's like
programming and cursive
uh so i i don't really use regular
expressions but
i can kind of go over the basic uses of
it you know basic uh filtering stuff
like that
and then forecast i'm i'm going to go
over you know just a few of the
functions that i use a little bit
um and the functions i kind of use a lot
in in modeling
um and i think also ggplot2 will be able
to be a good way to actually show
the actual for sure we'll be able to
show forecasts in
in in practice
so again this uh this video is going to
be pretty
uh ad hoc again just because
i wanted to do this video as more of a
kind of an eda standpoint
and also kind of explore many of the
main functions and kind of get a
you know a higher level more casual
um overview and explanation of these
these functions and packages
so tidy tuesday i'm going to call this i
guess like
tidy r for uh stringer
and four cats
okay
i'm also going to set my working
directory
to scripts okay
um okay
let's go back here so with reader
the main thing is read underscore csv
um one of the main reasons why i like to
use read underscore csv over
read.csv is if it frankly
parses the uh the data a little bit
better
and i just kind of like it better
because i think it looks cleaner
um so let's actually go into our thing
and maybe do we have any data
okay we can just say it df read csv
data by data dot csv
oh i'm so i'm gonna specify my
i'm gonna load in the here package just
because i like to use here
uh so i don't have to rewrite all of my
directory
so again we have read read underscore
csv it just breathes in the data
um there are a few things we can do um
you know we can specify the dolim um
if we like the elimination is equal to
you know it could be like commas or dash
ends and stuff like that
um generally it parses it pretty well
and it's able to detect it
so i i generally just kind of leave it
as is um
and then you can specify whether there
are column names or anything like that
so if you say like calls actually
read cs csv uh column
column names you can say true or false
column types you can specify the column
types
all this stuff i just don't do um i
rather i would rather to specify it
in my data cleaning section than the
actual reading in section
um so yeah and that's because mostly
um i'm pretty lazy about it and i don't
want to type all of it out because
oftentimes i'm changing
um data sources and changing data
queries so it's easier for me to
specify in a in the actual uh
analysis and data cleaning part so we
can also go into
um write csv um again
this isn't that interesting i i feel
like it the the it is important that we
know
this type of stuff but it really isn't
that interesting so
again we can say write csv or write
underscore
uh so you know
write csv we specify
uh we specify what we want to do that
you know we specify the data and then we
kind of give it
you know the file name which is like
test dot csv
um i guess you can all say append so if
you already have an existing file you
can say append equals true
by default it's false so just overwrite
it um but again
that's basically it for for the right
csv
true um
so yeah that's the reader package uh i
wanted to include in the video just
because
i see some people using read.csv and
then running into like encoding errors
and stuff like that and i find that read
underscore csv um generally handles it a
little bit better
but other than that again very
straightforward package
shouldn't i i feel like i've already
spent too much time
going over how to read in data um
because it's it is straightforward
okay so now we're actually going to the
stringer package
um obviously we're not going to do a lot
of like text analysis
of that um but i think i'm going to go
over mostly
like xt sdr detect
um so ester detect is probably the most
useful function uh so if we actually go
here and we're just gonna use this data
set
um often we're gonna use filter and we
might say like method is equal to
ko tko right
but sometimes we run into errors where
you know there might be spaces
on it and stuff like that so one thing
that we can do
right is we can actually uh clean our
data
by using um str squish
um s and then we can what i usually do
is str trim
oops
it's your trim and what this does sar
squish basically
um it removes the spaces on front
and ends the start on the end of the
string so often times when you're
at a database or someone's like manually
entering in data and specifically text
data
they might actually add they might
accidentally add in an extra space at
the end or the beginning
and then when you say you know filter uh
you know gender is equal to male
and you don't get any um
rows back is because there might be a
space so i generally always do str
squish
with an sdr trim to remove any of the
extra spaces both on the front and start
and also the duplicate spaces
uh because i find that causes a lot of
issues when you're doing a lot of like
filtering and manipulation like that
so that's how you basically clean most
character data
um you can also do str2 title
which will kind of you know it's it's
like the two proper in
uh in uh was it in excel
so in this case we wouldn't want to do
that to there but maybe with like
fighter we might do scr to
title and give it a fighter and i'll
kind of convert it i think i already
have that converter it might be already
just
done like that but those are some basic
like those are some basic string
cleanings that i will i will generally
do
um again with um when you're
once we have all these spaces removed
and stuff like that what we can also do
is like uh do a uh n a if
so if there's any you know just missing
space uh values that have like no
um values in it just a space uh we can
convert that into an n a
so if we actually let's see if i can
actually do this right here
um and i'll just give it what's like the
dog right we can see how the dog is and
we know right there
doesn't even change doesn't change
uh we can also say like if it's just an
empty space it'll convert that i'll
convert that so then when we do the uh
naf
it'll change to n a
right so so that'll change it to an n a
if we have any like missing values and
that's pretty useful too
um so and i think naf
also let me check this and af naf is
from deployer so
um again pretty useful thing too but you
can always do a mutate if else statement
too
okay so one of the more common things i
i do when i'm filtering for strings is
i'm never really going to do like a
filter and say fighter is equal to derek
brunson uh generally with strings i try
to do an sdr detect
so i'll say like scr detect fighter
and then derek brunson
um for me i think it's a little bit
easier um plus you can use regular
expressions
uh and in this case we don't really need
that so we can say detect and i'll still
find that and then
derrick b um and i'll find derek brunson
like that
um so yeah sdr detect um and then stress
questions your trim
are very useful functions when you're
kind of cleaning up the text data
but again uh once you get really into
like
uh pattern detection and stuff like that
uh that's when you kind of have to go
and do a little bit more research on
regular expressions
okay so once we actually have say like
all of our our character data or text
that are cleaned
uh we generally convert them to like
factors or something like that
um and four cats is kind of the package
to do it
so in this case let's see here we have
uh
yeah okay so i'll just say i'll select
the
weight class uh let's see here
i'll do uh i don't know kd
kd uh sprites
landed six strikes
landed takedowns and then
uh sub sub
we'll just do strikes
strike landed okay
so we have these um i'm just going to
separate weight class
see uh gender weight class
separate based off the uh what
sorry based off the little underscore so
that we have this
so one thing we might want to do is
you know let's just do a uh um ggplot
aes x equals weight class
actually we'll just first do a group by
so group by
a gender weight class
uh summarize and we'll say i don't know
strikes landed
strikes on it is equal to mean strikes
landed or maybe
we'll just do median so median
strike landed maybe doing n a dot
true okay so median strikes landed
again we kind of have a cool little
table
uh we can probably plot it out
right so pretty cool maybe a chord flip
uh yeah so we have that but if we notice
something
we notice that you know these weight
classes aren't
in order uh we kind of would probably
want them in order
additionally there are some some things
where like uh
maybe we um don't want catch weight and
stuff like that so
let's actually go back and kind of mess
with this data
so one thing we can do is we can just
filter it
so weight class uh does not equal
to uh let's say we'll actually use the
uh
sdr detect weight class
and then we'll say uh catch and we say
we do not want that
so we have that
so we no longer have catch weights um
actually i'm gonna do another thing too
i'm gonna say uh mutate
meaning strike landed is equal to
if else uh gender is equal to men
uh venus right granted else
that way they're flipped okay
so we have that um and one thing that i
kind of like about four cats
is that it's pretty useful when you're
doing a lot of ggpot
plotting stuff um with four cats if we
go back here
um it's all about handing handling
categorical or
factors um so let's actually go back to
the
gets with it reference and we can kind
of change it
um one of the main functions we can use
is that
you know uh let's say
weight class oh oops
weight class is equal to facet you can
say real level
or you can say facet actually we'll say
facet reorder
pass it and then we can say we want to
you know
arrange it by median strike landed
right um actually yeah
so we can do that but one thing we might
want to do is actually do like a custom
um facet so i'm going to actually
just do that so let's actually go
through here
and specify
um we can specify our actual classes so
in this case i'm actually just going to
use some case statements so weight class
is equal to weight class
order is equal to case
when and actually when i i'm going to
pull up the ufc weight classes
right so i'm going to say uh scr to
always say weight class
is equal to straw
straw weight
then one
okay um and then we'll say uh was it
flyweight so we have our
flywipe uh and then we have our
phantom weight and we have our
was our featherweight then we have our
lightweight uh middleweight
wait no it's uh oh welterweight
okay
welterweight uh middleweight
um where's our heavyweights uh
and then our heavyweights
okay so then we can just kind of change
that so three
four five six seven
then eight i wanna
make sure weight class is not found
oh wait class
okay uh now i'm just gonna do a little
sanity check so wait
uh weight class and then wait class
order uh fly away when
weight cost is equal to strongly it's
here
arrange by weight class
order straw weight flyweight phantom
weight
featherweight lightweight welterweight
middleweight heavyweight
okay sweet so we have that
um and then what we can do is just say
you know weight class
is equal to facet re order weight costs
function weight cost order
right and then with that uh we can
actually
uh plot it out and it should be in in
order
right so straw weights flyweights
phantom weights featherweights
lightweight heavyweight
etc pretty useful uh right there
um one of them more used
another useful function too is we can
kind of look at what's here
count count uh
method right
sometimes we were working with pretty
sparse levels
right so if we actually do a sort
equals true we can see like four is
other
could not continue dq overturn
tko sub you know sub uh submission
kotko decision basically
overturned dq could not contain other
should kind of be lumped
back into other so what we can actually
do
is mutate method and say facet
of lump and there's many ways to do it
um there's low frequency there's men
where you have to have a specific amount
of levels you just specify
um the levels i think the number of
levels you want
yeah and most frequent and then
in the proportion so we can also uh for
me i'll
say uh i don't know we'll say uh
well freak and method and let's see if
it actually does it by
auto and we can see it kind of just does
it right there
um a little freak so let me go back to
you can kind of actually go into the
actual facets
so lump low freak lump and
lump man uh will freak in the least
frequent
level ensuring other is still the
smallest level
um so maybe that yeah that's why it's
not
um and then we have lump n all levels
except for the end most frequent
um lump that appears fewer in uh prop
times and then min so there's definitely
a bunch of ways we can do this
in this case we kind of just want
everything
below one 160 so
back facet lump
uh facet
lump well freak and then
i wouldn't have pump oh men
nothing and equals 160 right
oh it's min
count method oh oops
there we go 161. so that way we can kind
of lump it
right um where if you need to get at
least 161 or also just hold up
everything together
cool and then once we have that right we
have our other we can kind of plot it
out so x equals method
y equals n
and then we can see like most it goes to
decision kltko
submission and then other which are
disqualifications and and could not
continue and stuff like that
so again pretty interesting pretty
useful
stuff too um if we really want to do
another thing too we can
um kind of go over one more function
from facet
so we know it's like a fast other we
might want to put other
right there right uh right before
decision so we can actually say like
mutate
method facet um
re-level and then method and we say uh
was it
uh other decision
and then just copy this in
right so that way uh other is at the
beginning even though i think visually
it doesn't make a lot of sense but you
know it's something where
we can kind of um specify where we want
our visuals or for our categorical
variables to be
at which is definitely pretty useful
when we're doing a lot of like
um very important plots that we want to
maybe like show on like an article and
stuff like that
so that's basically it for this video i
know i went pretty quick but
tidy r stringer and four cats um
definitely have
important functions uh but they only
have a few
um but they are used a lot so i just
want to do a video kind of
doing a high level summary of all of the
three packages and you know the main
things you would actually use from it
so with that being said i hope you guys
enjoyed the video and
i'll see you guys next time so teddy on